I'm just looking at my breakfast over
here
what do you got you've always got
liquids today
I'm on liquids today man why liquids
shout out Premiere yeah yeah I came in
here I freaked everybody out I was like
yeah what's up gang I got covered
everyone
uh not is this gonna count as like
spreading misinformation I don't want to
get us in trouble about what well I was
just saying a fun little prank that
folks can play on their friends is going
to you know a little shindig a little
function and immediately after dapping
up the first person you see is stating
that you have covered
how you doing I'm all right I got
covered yeah like a couple weeks ago
yeah no like like literally this way I
just that's a positive and then grab
their drink that's it from it oh what is
this
oh man is that that was that gin and
tonic keeping it clean and then kiss
them on the lips yeah yeah good to see
man
or say I have coveted and then if you
can immediately sneeze yeah
[Music]
if you can there's got to be someone who
can sneeze on command right yeah I don't
know that's a good question actually
there has to be someone who can just be
like yeah watch this
oh actually if you squeeze your
isn't there something you can do oh if
you smell pepper oh perhaps yeah
no the coveted thing jam it up your nose
that yeah yeah it causes it every single
time
damn now I'm thinking of stupid ass
doing a covet test out of kickback
just right there all everyone really
good that's we're just pouring up shots
in you're like hold on Mid conversation
you're like yeah no don't mind me I'm
just yeah he'll open the thing jam it up
your nose twisting it what's going on
you might take this what are you doing
sorry 10 times I gotta do it 10 times
other nostril
and then you take out the little thing
you drip the fluid in
like what oh a couple boogies are you
sick man no no I'm just well I might be
I might be well we'll find out we'll see
in 15 minutes
dude that has to be a new prank kit Auto
positive covet test
do you leave it like I'm gonna go grab a
beer can you can you keep an eye on that
for me make sure everyone touches that
you just I'll be right back and they're
all like
do you think he's sick is that a gym I
don't know no but you share drinks with
them for like I think I see a line yeah
you shared drinks with them for 10
minutes prior
thank you
yeah bother can I get another hit of
that thanks dude mine died you know
mine died
oh hold on one second
what is that dude
oh just a little Pfizer thing I don't
know
a little covet test I've been sick as
[__] all day
it's got like a little fever or some
[__] so just want to make sure I'm good
I got a gnarly fever right now oh my
head's kind of hot I just want to clear
the air you know make sure I'm solid see
if I need to dip
yeah doing it on the table where
everyone's pouring up is that's the wave
that's hilarious yeah you mine sorry
um that would be a great Tick Tock to
film like from afar yeah like some dude
just taking it out did you see this one
taking a kova test in the middle of the
kickback
taking a covet test in the middle of the
kickback did you see this one
have you seen this one okay wait I want
to send it to Luke remember Bobby
Holliday
now uh gay dude who will walk up to
random men and just start hitting on
them as a [__] yeah yeah he's got some
new ones
oh [__] they're good oh [__] dude one of
them had me like rolling send him let's
watch it it was three in the morning
because I haven't slept before midnight
in I don't know years now okay and uh
Alina's eye like she has on one eye
opener I'm like is that that's [__]
will you hold my phone so I can make a
quick tick tock thank you so much it's
already kind of recording and ready to
go yeah yeah yeah ready to go yeah this
one is great yeah let it rip
[Laughter]
I'll reset reset reset hear that you
speak
[Music]
you like that name yes
he said you're gonna stop giggling
Biggie oh wait packing up three seconds
you're not ready
[Music]
he's like it was all a dream
dude damn the audio is terrible coming
back dude anyway
um
the whole time the dude just keeps
licking his we have to watch the whole
thing it just keeps mocking him just
like talking like Biggie and then he
just drops the ACT it's hilarious like
this is just straight of harassment but
it's so funny he walked into some dude
in a 7-Eleven and he saw the company he
worked for and he goes oh hello you work
for Advance the guy's like yeah he goes
I'm starting there on Monday
and he just starts name dropping like
crazy and then the guy's like where you
come from he's like I used to work at
Tri-State and he's like try okay like
he's really just finessing the guy he's
like and I'm training you and you can
tell the dude's off put he's like yeah
he's like what's your name and he's like
Victoria
[Laughter]
he's like I'm gonna call you L boogie
he's like oh that sounds like a dude
name he's like I want you to call me
Victoria
oh man have you seen the Francesca
stugots thing probably but she does she
kind of does the same thing but she'll
just call up dudes like random guys and
be like hey we met in the bar two weeks
ago remember me and they're like uh
and she's like oh Francesca's two Gods
remember we like took two shots together
and you were telling me about your like
soccer league and they're like
oh yeah
oh yeah what's up oh [__] it's so funny
every guy like just Falls for it and
they're like man sorry I was
I was kind of teasing before I
definitely remember you when you first
called it's so funny like she'll get
them to say the most absurd [__] damn it
dude
and for bran dude
I [__] have covet yeah
you're just gonna slap it out that's how
you get it I'm sorry dude I got it
horrible case of covet yeah just a bunch
of lonely guys it's just like dudes are
[__] stupid yeah so dumb yeah you
know and single guys are like desperate
yeah so they're always like oh like just
on the off chance that this is a hot
girl that's yeah they're like yeah yeah
I remember you yeah totally yeah she
usually knows something about them
so I kind of feel like fans like sender
and they're like hey I met this guy can
you yeah pretend to
yeah
we don't have to watch it but I wonder
if there's gonna be a dude that can like
reverse it
like in the middle he just drops her
real name
it's like Francesca Oh you mean duh
she's like what like we actually did
meet last week he told me all about
these bits
what what yeah remember the one that you
didn't post and she's like uh yeah
there's that one you didn't post you
call that guy yeah
um yeah he's like a professional ice
licker
it's like the it's like it's like the
dude
that does like the fake omegles or
whatever uh you talk about that guy oh
they do where it's like it Cycles
through yeah and then it's him whoa whoa
yeah and then he'll like run out of the
back room yeah
that's so good it's such a good prank
it's genius yeah
I think I I've mentioned this before
back in the day we used to like take one
of our friends and like we put them on
like Omegle
Envy girl
and then you know the the dudes would be
all happy whoa and me and then other
people other dudes are crowded and be
like yeah
but yeah this is the guy oh here we go I
love your guys's energy it is definitely
a Vibe I love yours thanks
I well I have been around
wait no this is like scary yo what up
hello
laughs
[Laughter]
it's so [__] good hey nice bunk bed
thanks
um
oh yeah I'm going to USC no yeah
what major what major
porn that's my major
hilarious yeah good one dude that was
funny
laughs
the Mona Lisa man
I can't believe how many people go on
Omegle yeah man still not to film
content just a ghost to be on it's just
a Vibe that's [__] crazy yeah isn't
it mostly kids on there I mean no like
clearly this is people of all
I mean I guess yeah
no but remember when we did it yeah on a
ball and that's true yeah
yeah what did he the southern guy yeah
he had just gotten off work yeah we kept
getting him
that's how sad the the daytime cue for
Omegle is the same nine people yeah